et se trouver totalement démunite
lorsqu'on se retrouve face à une
démarche en ligne face à la préparation
d'un CV France Numérique ensemble trois
mots pour lutter contre la fracture
numérique une feuille de route qui court
jusqu'en 2027 et le département des
Yvelines est aussi concerné un excellent
retour puisque c'est 3 millions de
personnes qui ont été accompagnées au
plan national 13000 dans les ivelines
avec évidemment de l'aide pour accomplir
les démarches en ligne mais aussi et
surtout pour prendre en main les outils
numériques et per per mettre à chacun de
bénéficier de tout ce que le le
numérique apporte de positif pour
améliorer la vie quotidienne ce qui aide
ce sont les conseillers numériques au
nombre de 4000 sur toute la France ils
sont 30 à être actifs dans le
département des Yvelines au sein des
collectivité local les conseilles
numériques on peut les trouver à la fois
en mairie dans le des associations aussi
et également dans des bibliothèques ou
des médiathèques donc c'est l'idée c'est
vraiment qu'il puisse aussi se déplacer
au maximum pour être à la rencontre des
les habitants je fais aussi bien des
sensibilisations spécifiquement pour les
écoles que des accompagner les parents
pour ma part voir même aussi les
enseignants dans la maîtrise du
numérique des tablettes numériques qui
ont un programme qui a été renouvelé
encore cette année je peux aller à
domicile et c'est quelque chose que je
fais souvent puisque les gens apprécient
être accompagnés dans leur lieu familial
on va dire dans dans leur foyer objectif
du plan en 2027 avoir accompagné 8
millions de français avec 20000
conseillers